the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello welcome today we're going to start
talking we're going to talk about one
last new topic which has to do with
search so as you remember we're working
on our last topic the last topic was
probability and planning last lecture we
talked about probability the idea was
mostly mostly focused on Bayes theorem
Bayes rule that was a way of updating
our belief about a some situation based
on new information and this week in
design lab 12 you'll get a chance to use
that in a robot application the idea for
design lab 12 is going to be that a
robot is pedaling along a corridor with
some obstacles off to its left
and the idea will be you don't know
where the robot is but the robot will be
able to estimate where it is by the
signals that it receives from its left
facing sonars
so this is a very realistic type of
state estimation problem the idea is
going to be that at any given time T you
will have access to your previous belief
at time t minus 1 and you have access to
a new observation which is the sonar to
your left and based on those two bits of
information you will update your belief
which means that when you start out
you'll have no idea where you are but
that situation and should improve with
time ok so that's what we're going to do
in design lab 12 today we're going to
blast ahead and think about the other
important topic which is search so or
anything about planning we're going to
be planning ahead we're not going to
just react to the situation that's given
to us we're going to try to figure out
what's the right thing to do in the
future and to do that we're going to
think about all the things that we could
possibly do search through that space
and figure out the one that's quote best
and we'll have to define best somehow
just to get going I want to show you a
very simple kind of a search problem
search problem this is called the 8
puzzle the idea is to make a plan to go
from this configuration which we'll call
a state to this configuration which
we'll call the goal state and on each
move you get to to move one of the tiles
into the free space so I could move the
8 to the right or the 6th down those are
the only two things that I could do in
the start state so I have to make up my
mind which of those I would like to do
and I would like to believe that
ultimately after a series of moves I'm
going to be able to perturb this state
into that state ok and you can imagine
sort of guessing and will estimate in a
moment how big is the guest space I mean
if the guest space only has like four
elements in it guessing is a fine
strategy if the guests stay if the guest
space guest space has a lot more
elements in that guessing is probably
not a good idea
so I previously ran our search
algorithms the ones that will develop
during lecture on this problem and
here's the solution that our search
algorithm came up with
it's not exactly what you might do the
first time you touched it okay I made it
if you were counting I made 22 moves the
question is how difficult was that
problem and how good was that solution
was that a good solution or a bad
solution is there a better solution how
much work did I have to do in order to
calculate that solution so to get a
handle on that let's start by asking a
simple question how many configurations
are there I mean I got there in 22 what
was the space of things I had to look
through how many different board
configurations exists so think about
that for 20 seconds talk to your
neighbor and figure out whether it is 8
squared 9 squared 8 factorial 9
factorial or none of those
so how many board configurations do you
see
raise your hand show me a number of
fingers so I can figure out roughly how
keywords excellent
so very good participation and nearly
100% correct so the answer is number
four you can think about this what if
you took all the tiles out and threw
them on the floor and put them in one at
the time well you would have nine
possibilities for where you wanted to
put the first one then you would have
eight possibilities for where you wanted
to put the second one then you have
seven possibilities for where you put
the third one etc etc so even though the
space doesn't have a number on it it's
still sort of counts and so you end up
with nine factorial and the point is
nine factorial it's a big number nine
factorial is 3 6 - 8 8 0 so if you
thought about simply guessing that's
probably not going to work all that well
right even if you guess you have on each
so there's 30 there's a third of a
million different configurations that
you have to look at and that's if you
didn't lose track of things if you lost
track of it of mice coming up almost
anyway it looks like it's chopped off at
the top so ignore that for now look over
here so even if you didn't confuse
yourself there's sort of a space of a
third a million things to look at and if
you confused yourself there's even more
so it's not a huge problem by computer
science standards but it's certainly not
the trivial problem it's not something
that you can just guess and get right so
what we want to do today is figure out
an algorithm for conducting a search
like that we'd like to figure out the
algorithm analyze how well it works
optimize it and try to find out a way to
find the best solution where best for
this particular problem would mean
minimum
half-length so figure out the best
solution by considering as few cases as
possible obviously if you enumerate all
the cases that should work the problem
is that we'll be interested to solve
problems where that enumeration is quite
large even here the enumeration is quite
large so this thing about the algorithm
and I'll think about the algorithm by
way of an even simpler more finite
problem what if I thought about a grid
of possible locations where I could be
maybe this is the intersection so
streets in Manhattan I want to go from
point A to point I what's the minimum
distance path I hope you probably can
all figure that out but what I want to
do is write an algorithm that can figure
that out and then if we write the
algorithm well we'll be able to use it
for the tile problem which is not quite
so easy to do the way we're going to
think about doing that is to organize
all of our possible paths through that
maze in a tree so if I started at a I
have a decision to make I could either
go to B or D then if I went to say B I
could either then go to a or e a or C or
E I've organized them alphabetically for
no particularly good reason just I
needed some order so then if I went from
A to B it's to a say then I have I could
either go from B from A to B or D that's
illustrated here so the idea then I it
works ok so now it looks like they're
all three working so the idea is think
about the original problem the original
problem is find the shortest path
through some grid I want to go from a to
I and I'll think about all the possible
paths on a tree then the the problem is
that for the kinds of problems we're
going to look at that tree could be
infinite in life oh that's a bummer that
means that the strategy
of building the tree and then searching
it is probably not a good strategy so
what we'll do instead is we'll try to
write the algorithm in such a way that
we construct the tree and search for the
best solution all in one pass then
hopefully if we find the solution in
some finite number of steps will only
have built part of the tree but will
have built the part that has the answer
okay so the idea then is going to be
think about what is the path we want to
take by thinking about the tree of all
possible paths but what we want to do is
write code that will construct the tree
on the fly while it's considering how
good were all the different nodes okay
so how we're gonna do that so in so
we'll be working in Python not
surprisingly we'll represent all the
possible locations we'll call those
states so the problem will have States
ABCD and we'll just represent those by
strings we're just and that that makes
it flexible that makes it arbitrary then
we'll think about transitions not by
enumerating them remember we don't want
to enumerate them because there could be
infinitely many of them so how is the
other way we could do it well body that
information in a program will write a
procedure called successor that will
given the current state and action
figure out the next state so that's a
way that we can incrementally build the
tree so imagine here if I told you a and
I took option I took action 0 or 1 if I
started an A and I executed action 0 1 I
would end up in B or D respectively so I
tell you the current state and the
current action and the successor program
then will return to you the next the new
State that's all we need to construct
the tree on the fly then to specify the
particular problem with interest I'll
have to tell you where you start so I'll
have to do
fine initial state and I'll have to tell
you where to end I could just tell you
the final state but in some of the
problems of the type that we will want
to do there are there could be multiple
acceptable answers so I don't want to
just give you the final state I'll give
you a test I'll give you another
procedure called goal test and that goal
test went past an input which is a state
will tell you whether or not you reach
the goal that way for example all the
even numbered squares could satisfy the
goal if that were the problem of
interest or all the states on the right
could satisfy the goal it's just a
little bit more flexible so the idea
then is that in order to represent that
tree I will do it by specifying a
procedure called successor and
specifying the start state and the gold
test so here's how I might set that up
for the simple Manhattan problem that I
showed that I started with so I want
ultimately to have something called
successor that eats of state and an
action I've built the structure of the
of Manhattan into a dictionary the
dictionary lists for every state
abcdefgh
I for every state it associates that
state with a list of possible next
States so if I'm in a I could next be in
B or D I could next be and B or D I've
organized these arbitrarily in
alphabetical order so I can remember
what's going on so the next states are
all in alphabetical order the number of
next states depends on the state I'm not
going to worry about that too much
I'm just going to order the app I'm just
going to specify the action as an
integer 0 1 2 3 however many I need so
the possible actions are taken from that
list the possible action might be do
action 0 do action 1 do action too so if
I did action 2 starting on state II I
would be go to so action start at 0 so 0
1 2 I would go to stay tough ok it's not
all clear the initial state is a and the
goal state is return s equal to I so if
s is equal to I it returns true if s is
not equal to I it returns false ok I'm
not quite done that's enough to
completely specify the tree but now I
have to build the tree in Python not
surprisingly from our object-oriented
past we will use an object-oriented
representation for that tree so we'll
specify every node in the tree as an
instance of the class search node search
node is trivial search node simply knows
what was the action that got me here
who's my parent and what's my current
state so when you make a new node you
have to tell the node you have to tell
the constructor those three things so
what was the action that got me here
what's my current state and who is my
parent knowing the node you're supposed
to know the entire path that got you
here so we'll also add a method which
reports the path so if I happen to be in
node II my path ought to be I started in
a I took action 0 and got to B and then
I took action to and got to E and so
this subroutine is intended to do that
if my parent is none which will happen
for the initial state simply report that
the path to me is none a however if I'm
anybody other than the initial State at
the initial node sorry if I'm anybody
other than the initial node
then figure out the description of the
path to my parent and add the action
that got me here and my state so that's
what this is okay so what are we doing
so we specify a problem by telling you
the successor sub the successor function
the start state and the goal tasks and
then we provide a class by which you can
build nodes to construct on the fly the
search tree okay now we're ready to
write the algorithm so here's the
pseudocode for the algorithm what do we
do we initialize so we're gonna be doing
a thorough this is very confusing I'm
trying to solve a search problem to
solve the search problem I'm going to
search through the tree okay so I'm
gonna think about the state of my search
through the tree my way of something
we'll call the agenda very jargony word
I completely apologize for it I didn't
invent it
it's what everybody calls it sorry so
we'll call it the agenda is the state
this the agenda is the set of nodes that
I'm currently thinking about so I'll
initialize that to contain the starting
node then I'll just systematically just
keep repeating the same thing over and
over again take one of the nodes out of
the agenda think about it
replace that node by its children while
I'm doing that two things are supposed
to happen I'm supposed to construct the
search tree but I'm also going to be
looking over my shoulder to see if I
just constructed a child who is the
answer because if I just constructed the
answer I'm dying
okay so initialize the agenda to contain
just the starting node then repeat the
following steps remove one node from the
agenda and that node
children to the agenda and keep going
until one of two things happens either
you found it
go test true return true or the agenda
got empty in which case must not be a
solution okay if I if I've removed all
of my options and still haven't found
anything then there's no solution okay
so what's the program looked like it's
actually remarkably simple especially
when you think about just how hard the
problem is imagine if you wanted to do
that tiles problem with a kind of a very
simple-minded if this then this if this
then this right we're talking about of a
third of a million different ifs right
well that's probably not the right way
to do it all right so this program is
going to end up being about this long
it'll fit on this page and it's going to
be able to handle that case or even
harder cases so the idea so we find the
search procedure the search procedure is
something that's going to take the
initial state the goal test the possible
actions and the successor subroutine the
successor procedure that's everything
you need to specify the problem and it's
going to return to me the optimal path
so first step one initialize the agenda
to contain the start node okay I want to
put the start node a well there's a
chance I want this procedure to be
general purpose right there's a chance
that that start node is the answer okay
so take care of that first
so if if you're already there return the
answer ok the path to the answer is me
so I'm trying to create the agenda I'm
trying to put the first node into the
agenda there's a chance that first node
is the answer if that first nodes the
answer returned the path to me which is
take no action you're here ok but that's
not likely to be the case for the kinds
of questions we ask in which case we
will create a list that contains one
node which is the node that represents
the start node then
repeat remove a node which will call the
parent from the agenda and substitute
replace that node that's that we that we
pulled out of the agenda replaced that
with the children so while not empty of
agenda empty is some kind of a pseudo
routine that I'm going to fill in in a
minute
while the agenda is not empty get an
element out of the agenda which will
call the parent then I want to think
about all the children well there's a
list of possible action so for a and
actions do all the do the following
things each parent can have multiple
children one for every possible action
so for a in action figure out what would
be the new state well the new state is
just the successor of the parents need
remember the parent is a node right the
parent is a node we're constructing
nodes in the search tree but nodes know
their state so figure out the new state
which is the successor of my parent the
guy that I pulled out in the agenda make
a new node which corresponds to this
child then ask the question did this did
the new state satisfy the goal test if
it did the answer is the path to the new
node okay so create a new state which is
the successor of the parent under the
under the given action a create a new
node see if it's the end if it is just
return I'm done return from search
otherwise add it again one of these
pseudo procedures will fill that in in a
minute
add the new node into the agenda ok so
there's several things that could happen
when I run this loop so if the node has
no children
nothing is sorry I will take out the
pair
and not put anything back in if the node
has multiple children I could take out
one node and put in more nodes then I
took out so the agenda could get longer
so the agenda so so the agenda could
either increase in length or decrease in
length as a result of spinning around
this loop also we could either identify
a goal or fail to identify a goal so as
it's increasing and decreasing we either
will or won't find an answer okay
now the trick the only thing that makes
this complicated is that order matters
so those pseudo operations whatever they
were so get element and add exactly how
I get element and exactly how I add it
to the agenda affects the way I conduct
the search let's think of something very
simple let's always remove the first
item remove the first node from the
agenda and replace it by its children so
pull out the first node and put back
into the beginning of the agenda the
children of the first node okay so how I
would start out in step zero I would put
the start node into the agenda so now
there's one element in the agenda the
start node then on the first pass
through the Liu I would pull out that
that's the first node in the agenda
there's only one node in the agenda so
that is the first one pull out the first
one and replace it by its children its
children are a B and a D I'm
representing the nodes in this notation
by the path because the same state can
appear multiple times in the tree
notice that I could walk aibee aibee
right which would correspond to the same
state being repeated in the tree so I
can't when I'm writing it down here
represent the node by a state but I can
represent a node by a path so on I'm the
first pass through the loop pull out the
first item in the agenda which is a and
push back that is children where a
children are a B and a B okay so now on
the second pass the rule is pull out the
first guy and replace it by the children
so now the first guy is a B so I'm here
so poo that guy out and replace him by
his children his children are a B a a B
C and a be e a D is left over the number
of elements in the agenda got bigger
next step pull out the first item in the
agenda replace it by his children the
first item in the agenda is ABA the
children of ABA are a B a B and a B a D
okay so notice the structure of what's
going on so ignore the stuff in the
bottom and just watch the picture on the
top so I start by putting a in the
agenda then it's children then it's
children then it's children so when I
implemented the algorithm take out the
first and replace it by its children I'm
searching along the depth first I'm
going deeper and deeper into the tree
without fully exploring all the
horizontal spaces so I'm I'm tracing a
line down that way so if you imagine
this tree this then I've only
represented the first three layers of
nodes here this tree goes on forever
right it's an infinite tree because you
can walk around in that man
Matan grid forever there's no limit to
how long you can walk a lot walk around
so although I'll only listing the first
three the tree in principle goes on
forever and this algorithm will have the
feature that it walks along the left
edge
we call that depth-first search because
we're exploring depth first as opposed
to breath okay that results because of
our rule the rule was replaced the first
node by his children let's think about a
different rule let's replace the last
node by his children now so we start by
initializing the agenda to the node that
represents the start state so that's a
the path a then replay to pull out the
last node in the agenda well that's a
and stick in and replace it by its
children it's children are still a B and
a D just like before now the answer
differs from the previous answer because
when I pull out the last node I'm
pulling out a D now instead and now I
replace a D by its children which are a
DAA d-ii
a DG repeat and what I've got is a
different but still depth-first search
so so I've looked at two different
orderings pull out the first node from
the agenda and replace it by his
children pull out the last node and
replace it by his children both of those
algorithms give an exploration of the
decision tree searching out depth-first
so it's going to try to exhaustively go
through the entire depth before it tries
to to explore the width
as an alternative think about a slightly
more complicated rule remove the first
element from the agenda and add is
children to the end of the agenda so
initialize it with the start state so a
pull out the first element from the
agenda that's a and replace it by its
children which is a BA D now pull out
the first guy well the first guy is a B
and put its children at the end its
children are ABA ABC a be e ABA ABC a be
e and they are now put at the end so
that on the next step I'll pick up a D
the guy at the beginning and put a DS
children at the end it cetera etc etc
etc etc etc the idea being an out the
pay no attention to the bottom for a
moment and just think about the pattern
that you see at the top so in this order
where we remove the first node and put
its children at the end of the agenda
has the effect of exploring breadth
first so we call that a breadth-first so
the idea is we've got this generic set
of tools that let us construct search
trees but the order by which we
manipulate the agenda plays a critical
role in how the search is conducted and
the two that that epitomize the two
extreme cases are what would happen if I
replace the last node by its children or
what would happen if I remove the first
node and put its children's at the end
those two structures have names because
they happened so often we'll call the
first one a stack in the second one a
queue the stack based is going to give
us depth first the queue based is going
to give us breadth-first so stack
how do you think about a stack a state
you think about a stack by saying okay
I've got a stack a stack is like a stack
of dishes so here's my table and I'm
gonna rack my dishes up I'm gonna put
them on a stack so so I make a snack
okay I made the stack push a one push a
nine push a three push a one push a nine
push a three that's how I do a stack
then pop okay when I pop the three comes
out then pop then the nine comes out
then push it - - then pop now the - two
comes out okay
it's stack based so the last end becomes
the first out that was the rule that we
wanted to have for the depth-first
search and we it's very easy to
implement this we can implement it as a
list and all we need to do is be careful
about how we implement the push and pop
operators so if we set up the push
operator to simply append to the end and
then pop pop ordinarily pops from the
end and so we'll get the behavior of a
stack so that gives me then the rules
that I would want to use for those
procedures that did get element and add
I will use these stack based operators
the other alternative is a queue so a
queue is different a queue is like when
you're waiting in line at stop and shop
so the queue is I've got this queue here
and I've got the server over here so the
first person who comes into the queue so
say I push one so now one goes into the
queue then another person walks up well
he's another the second person lines up
behind the first person
then I push a three but the way the
queue works is that when I pop the next
person off the queue I take the head of
the line so the one comes out if I pop
again the nine comes out if I then push
a -2 and pop then the next person in the
queue comes out and it's like that so
it's queue based versus stack based and
the queue base is the one that we're
want to do for a breadth-first
Organization and the implementation of a
queue is very trivially different from
the implementation for a stack the only
difference is that I'll manipulate the
list by popping off from the head of the
queue so pop takes an optional argument
which when 0 tells you the what the
argument tells you which element to pop
so when you specify the zeroth one it
takes it from the head of the queue that
makes it very easy now to replace the
pseudo procedures with real procedures
if I wanted to implement a depth-first
search I would replace the create a list
that contains the agenda with creating a
stack that will contain the agenda so
create a new stack the agenda is a stack
and then rather than simply sticking the
node the start node into a list I will
push it into the stack so agenda is a
stack agenda dot push the initial node
and then every time I want to get a new
element out our agenda dot pop it and
every time I want to put something into
it our agenda dot push it other than
that it looks just the same
as the pseudocode that i showed earlier
so there's an implementation then for a
depth-first search if I wanted instead
to do breadth it's trivial change the
word stack to the word queue now create
an agenda that is a queue but queues
have the same operations push and pop
and empty that stacks have so nothing
else in the program changed all I needed
to do is change the structure of the
thing that's holding the agenda
everything else just follows okay you
may have noticed so that's everything we
need right now what I want to do is
think through examples and think about
the advantages and disadvantages with
different kinds of searches and I want
to go on to the second step that I
raised in the first slide I want to
think about how do i optimize the search
as I said even that simple little tile
problem even the eight puzzle eight
sounds easy right
even the eight puzzle took had a third
of a million different states I don't
necessarily want to look through all of
them I want to think now about these
different search strategies and how
optimal are they relative to each other
and are there ways to improve that now
some of you may have noticed that none
of that all of these paths don't seem
equally good so take a minute think
about it remember the problem the
problem was this walk around Manhattan
problem I wanted to go from a to I this
was the tree of all possible paths from
a to I what I'd like you to do is think
about whether all of those paths are
important could we get rid of some of
them
so the question is could I throw away
some of the terminal nodes notice that
I'm using the word terminal kind of
funny here the tree keeps going right
the tree is actually infinite in length
so by terminal I just mean this Row 3 so
could I throw away some of the nodes in
Row 3 and in particular how many of them
could I throw away 0 what 2 4 6 or 8
raise your hand with the funny coding
and the answer is come on raise your
hand raise your hands blame it on your
neighbor right that's the whole point
okay it's 2/3 5 and 1/3 4 so how'd you
get 5 and 4 yes
you're walking around it and you're
trying to get over the Vai and if you
spun around in this loop and came back
to a that would probably be a bad path
right so revisiting a place you've been
before is probably a bad idea if what
your goal was was to get from a day I in
the shortest possible distance right so
that's exactly right so I would like to
identify instances where I'd go back to
where I started so for example that a
that a is bad right that means I went
back to the start place I'm just
starting over so if I think about those
I can identify by red all the places
where I'm repeating so a be a don't
really care what happens after that
ABCD well that's B again so that's just
brain-dead right so I can actually
remove a fair amount of the tree by
simply getting rid of silliness right
don't start the path over again
right yeah we're over means if you come
to a place you've been before
stop looking there that's not the right
answer okay and so you can see there
that there were actually deleted half of
the tree so the number of nodes on the
third line was sixteen and eight of them
had the property that they repeated yes
so this being he so there's no reason to
consider this D even a word
yes so this D seems quickly inferior
batteries yes that absolutely true so
there may be so this is a very simple
rule for removing things you're thinking
of a more advanced rule so if you saw if
there's a shorter path to a particular
place don't look at the longer path
you're absolutely right so in fact there
might be more severe pruning that you
could do so there might have been an
answer that was bigger than eight right
so you're absolutely right okay so for
the but let me ignore that for the
moment and come back to it in about four
slides you're absolutely right so what
we want to do now is take that idea of
throwing away silly paths and formalize
it so that we can put it into the
algorithm and we'll think about that as
pruning rules
so the first pruning rule is the easy
one don't consider any path that visits
the same state twice so that doesn't
pick up your case but it does pick up
eight cases here so that's easy to
implement all we need to do is down here
where we're thinking about whether this
is a good state to add or not we just
ask is it in the path so if the state
that I'm about to put in the path is
already in the path don't put it there
right if you don't shove it back into
the agenda it'll get forgotten
so before you shove it into the agenda
ask yourself the question is it already
in the path and so I do that here keep
in mind I popped out an element called
the parent I'm looking at the children
the children's state is called new state
so I asked his new state in the parents
path so parent got in path of new state
so that means I have to write in path in
path is easy it's especially easy if we
use recursion so in path says if my if
my state is state then return true I'm
in the path if that's not true and I
don't have a parent then that means I'm
the search state that means it wasn't in
the path and if neither of those is true
asked the same question of my parent so
that makes it recursive right so it's
considered two cases that could either
make it true or false it would be true
if I'm currently sitting on a node that
happens to be the same state it would be
false if I i recurse the whole way back
to the start state and hadn't found it
yet so there are two termination States
I landed on a state in the path that was
the same as new stay or I ran the whole
way back to the start state and didn't
find it
those two terminate by doing returns
return true return false the other
option is that I don't know the answer
ask my parent
so just recurse on empath and ask my
parent to do the same thing so that's
the way I can figure out I can implement
pruning rule one now pruning rule two if
multiple actions lead to the same state
only thing about one of them that
actually doesn't happen on the Manhattan
grid problem but you can imagine search
cases where there are three different
things that you could do in fact you saw
some of those when you're you're coding
the robot last week so there were
multiple ways you could end up at the
state at the end of the hall so you
could get there by being there and
laughs which you hit the wall or you
could get there by being here and moving
left both of them left you in the same
place so if you're planning a search you
don't need to distinguish among those
because they take the same amount of
steps so since they take the same amount
of steps we don't need to search further
so we can collapse them
that's called pruning rule 2 that's also
easy to implement what we do is we keep
track of for every parent what are all
of its children if the parent already
has a child at that place throw away the
excess children doesn't sound good so
keep track of how many child States I
have make a list and if I'm if it if the
new state didn't satisfy the goal ask if
it's already in the list of children if
it's already there passed don't do
anything otherwise do pruning rule 1 and
then before you push it into the agenda
also push it in to the list of new
children that's a way of making sure
that if there's multiple ways to get the
same state you only keep track of one so
that's an additional pruning role so now
let's think about how we would implement
these let's think about the solution to
a problem where we want to apply
depth-first search to on this Manhattan
problem to get from a to I so let's
think about
so I want to think about how do I apply
depth-first search
to that problem okay so think about the
agenda so the agenda I initialize it
with the node that corresponds to the
start state so that's a I'm doing
depth-first what's the rule for
depth-first pop the last guy replace it
by his children
okay so pop the last guy what's the last
guy
the last guy is a replace it by its
children what's the children of a well
there's two of them a B and a D okay so
I'm done with the loop for the first
level so pop the last guy that's a D
replace it by his children what are the
children of a D well what could D do D
could go to a or E or G a Zed so I don't
want that one so I'll think about a and
G so a D and G by the way stop me if I
make a mistake it's really embarrassing
okay pop the end a DG who's the possible
children of a DG a DG well it could go
back to D but that's stupid so ad gh
seems to be the only good one
pop the last one ad gh and whose his
children ad gh aggh has children e and I
h EG and i but I don't want G because
that's brain-dead so ad ad GH e or I
and that one one right because I got to
a everyone see what I did I tried to
work out the algorithm manually so the
idea then was that I visited so how much
work did I do
I visited one two three four five six
seven and then I found it so I did seven
visits and I got the right answer okay
so both of those are good sevens a small
number and getting the right answer both
of those are good things and in general
if you think about the way a depth-first
search works here's a transcript of what
I just did so this will be posted on the
online version so that you can see it
even though it's not handed out to you
now so you can look this up on the web
so in general depth-first search won't
work for every problem it happened to
work for this problem
in fact it happened to be very good for
this problem but it won't work for every
problem because it could get stuck it
could run forever in a problem with
infinite domain this problem has
infinite domain so if I were to choose
my start and end state judiciously I
could get it stuck in an infinite loop
that's a property of depth-first search
it oh it's a even when it finds a path
that doesn't necessarily find the
shortest path well that's a bummer but
it's very efficient in its use of memory
so it's not a completely brain-dead
search strategy but it's usually
brain-dead so let's think about
breadth-first search as an alternative
again all we need to do is switch the
idea thinking about stacks versus queues
take off the beginning add to the end
that's the way queues work so now let's
do the same problem with a breadth-first
search so I start with the
I put in a I pop off the head of the
queue and stuff the children at the end
okay so I pop off the beginning and
stuff the children a B a B that looks
right that's the end of past one now I
pop off the beginning and stick in the
children what are the children of a B
well a B could go to a CEA is brain dead
so ABC ABC or a b e ABC or a be e that
looks right now pop off this guy a D and
put his children at the end ad that's a
de and a DG I don't think I made a
mistake yet pop off the first guy ABC
stick in his children ABC a b c could go
to b4 f it looks like f is the anyone
that makes any sense
ABC that looks right a B yeah prettiest
children a B II he could go to B that's
brain dead D F or H D F right a B thank
you
okay I'm supposed to be doing a ve
followed by something a be followed by
something I don't want B D is fine F is
fine and H is fine D F and H okay so far
oh no it's not right okay what'd I do
wrong okay next pop off a D this is why
we have computers right we don't
normally do this by hand okay so ad okay
if I had a de I could do B that seems ok
d seems bad F or H so that's look like
bfh okay ad g okay a d g looks like h is
my only option
a b c f a b c f looks like i could do
e or i finally okay now the only
question is whether i got the right
number of states let's assume i get 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 14 15 16 okay
which happens to be the right at or at
least it happens to be the answer i got
this morning when i was at breakfast
okay
so what did I just do so I just did
breath for a search here's a transcript
16 matches good breath for a search has
different set of properties notice that
it took me longer but because it's
breadth-first and because each row
corresponds to an increasing path length
it's always guaranteed to give you the
shortest answer that's good so it always
gives you the shortest answer
it's requires more space I mean you can
see that just on the chalkboard right
and also it still didn't take care of
your problem so this still seems like
there's too much work so I looked at 16
different places I did 16 visits
there's just something completely wrong
about that because there's only nine
states how could it take more visits
then there are states so that just
doesn't sound right and it's for exactly
your point
so there's another idea that we can use
which is called dynamic programming the
idea in dynamic programming the
principle is if you think about a path
that goes from X to Z through Y the best
path from X to Z through Y is the sum of
two paths the best path from X to Y and
the best path from Y to Z okay if you
think about that that has to be the case
and if we further assume that we're
going to do breadth-first then the first
time that we see a state is the best way
to get there so what we can do then in
order to take care of your case is keep
track of the states we've already
visited
if we've already visited a state
it appears earlier in the tree there's
no point to thinking about it further
that's the idea of dynamic programming
and that's also easy to implement it all
we need to do is keep track of all those
places we've already visited
so we make a dictionary called visited
so in visited so I initialized before I
start looking at the children I
initialized right after I set up the
initial contents of the agenda I create
this dictionary called visited and every
time I visit a new state I put that stay
in the visit list then before I add the
child to the agenda I ask is the child
already in the visit list if the child
is already there well forget it I don't
need it otherwise just before you push
the new stay remember now that that's an
element that's been visited so the idea
then is that by keeping track of who
you've already looked at you can avoid
looking so if there's a depth 3 way to
get to D and a depth 2 and I don't need
to worry about the the previous ones
because it's already in the visit list
yes
modifying the code for the different
places I slipped and could have removed
that line I think you're right I'll have
to think about it but I think you're
right so if that line magically
disappears from the online version he's
right okay
so now one last problem I want to see if
I can figure out what would happen with
dynamic programming so I want to do
breadth-first and just as a warning I'm
hypoglycemic at this point so there may
be more errors than usual so I need to
keep track of two things I need to keep
track of the visit lists and I need to
keep track of the agenda so there's two
lists I have to keep track of okay let's
start out by saying that the agenda
contains the restart element that's a
that means we visited a it's
breadth-first so i want to take the
first guy out of the queue and add his
children to the end of the queue you
take the first guy out of the queue add
his children age children are B and D
which means that I've now visited the
indeed now I want to take out the first
guy from the queue a B and I want to put
his children at the end of the queue
okay a beast children are a that's been
visited C not visited and E not visited
so a b c e but that visits C and E
now I want to take out ad and put its
children at the end ad is a eg a is
visited E is visited the truth is just G
so ad GE and that visits G then I want
to take out ABC pretty in its children
ABC a BC oh dear
a B and I'm looking up there I said I
see Megan okay ABC ABC could be B or F B
or Applebee's no good which leaves F but
that visits F so now a B II okay a B II
so that could be B D F H be visited D
visited F visited H okay that visits H
now take out a DG children of a DG a DG
two children D and H D and H they're
both there that didn't work there are no
children of AD G a B C F a B C F three
children see e I see visited II visited
I done found the right answer one two
three four five six seven eight eight
visits so I've got the same answer and
its optimal and I did fewer than nine
visits nine was the number of states so
this algorithm will always have those
properties so the dynamic programming
alright forgot us line hmm okay the
dynamic programming with breadth-first
search will always find the best it'll
never take longer than the number of
states so in this problem that had a
finite number of states even though it
had an infinite number of paths because
you could go around in circles it'll
still never take more than the number of
states and all that it requires to
implement is to maintain two lists
instead of one so the point then is that
today we looked at a variety and we
looked at two real different kinds of
search algorithms depth-first search and
breadth-first search and we looked at a
number of different pruning rules
pruning rule one don't go to someplace
that you've already visited pruning rule
- if you have two children they go to
the same place only thing about one of
them you can consider dynamic
programming to be a third pruning rule
because that's the effect of it and the
final announcement
don't forget about Wednesday so have a
good week